[Musique]
maman
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire et si l'on revenait sur le
pr noyelles contraction de il est de l
le dictionnaire robert l'introduit dans
sa version en ligne ce qui a créé une
polémique jusqu'au sommet de l'état le
mois dernier la bataille contre le au
kiss me faisant des âges déjà rage
c'était la goutte d'eau qui faisait
déborder le vase mais qu'est ce qui se
joue dans toutes ces controverses autour
des pronoms genre et de la non binarité
de l'écriture inclusive ou du sexisme de
la langue française pour en débattre
nous avons invité lille à braunschweig
vous êtes chercheuse en théorie
politique spécialisé en philosophie
féministe chargé de cours à sciences po
vous venez de publier votre premier
livre ne trizay émancipation par le
neutre aux liens qui libèrent je vous ai
reçue à sa sortie c'était dans
l'émission du 28 octobre
alors se prononcer elle si je vous
demande de l'utiliser pour moi par
exemple ou pour qui que ce soit d'autre
est ce que vous le ferez oui tout à fait
je le ferai je le fais déjà en fait déjà
de le faire dans l écrit et même à
l'oral et même à l'oral mais à ce moment
là vous le fait parce qu'on vous le
demande où vous le faites pas ce que
vous avez des doutes alors il m'arrive
de le faire donc pour deux raisons soit
parce que une personne se reconnaît dans
ce pronom et demande qu'on utilise pour
pour la désigner ou alors pour parler de
dépôt le ou la désigner voilà mais une
personne donc pour la désigner
pour parler en général de personnes d'un
groupe de personnes dont on ne
connaîtrait pas le genre à priori et
donc voilà pour faire une contraction de
ils et elles et pour inclure aussi dans
ce groupe de personnes les personnes non
binaire michel maffesoli vous êtes
sociologue philosophe professeur émérite
à la sorbonne vous êtes l'un des
théoriciens de la postmodernité votre
dernier essai paru chez l'ère des
soulèvements aux éditions du cerf phcie
vous demande de parler de moi en
utilisant le pronom yale vous le ferez
ou pas non pas du tout non du tout
si je vous répond d'une manière
proustienne c'est pas mon genre voilà
donc
considère que cette ce sont des
imbécilités dans le sens étymologique du
terme une bacillus à dire ceux qui ne
savent pas marché avec les deux bâtons
que sont le bon sens et la droite raison
réunis et j'arrive son sexe masculin sa
règle imbécile it est de mon point de
vue dans ce sens étymologique et cela
traduit chaque fois que si on le met en
perspective chaque fois qu'il ya la
décadence de quelque chose vous savez
que mon dada c'est dire que les en train
de tomber un des cas d'art est en train
de tomber la modernité eh bien on a ce
genre d'imbécilités qui ressorte voilà
cela dit je ne pense pas que ce soit
très important enfin liogier vous êtes
philosophe sociologue professeur des
universités vous exercer à sciences po
aix en provence vous êtes l'auteur de ce
populisme qui vient c'est est paru chez
textuel en 2013 et de descentes au coeur
du mal paru aux liens qui libèrent et
c'est aux liens qui libèrent que vous
dirigez avec dominique quessada la
collection trans qui édite le livre de
lille à braunschweig si je vous demande
d'utiliser le pronom yale pour moi ou
pour qui que ce soit d'autre ça vous
posera pas de problème moi ça ne posera
aucun problème je veux dire de problème
a priori mais mon problème ça serait que
je suis pas encore habitué donc
peut-être que je ne ferai pas parce
qu'il faudrait que je travaille la
question tout est une question
d'exercice je pense que tu voulais dire
d'habitude et d'exercice est à dire
qu'on doit exercer ses habitudes on peut
être passif par rapport à ses habitudes
puis on peut être actif la promesse de
la modernité c'est justement d'être
actif dans moi j'essaye d'être actif et
de modifier mes habitudes pour
m'améliorer
patrick charaudeau
cette linguiste professeur émérite à
l'université paris xiii d'être le
fondateur du centre d'analysé du
discours votre dernier livre s'intitule
la langue n'est pas sexiste c'est paru
au bord de l'eau une question qu'on
abordera au cours de cette émission ce
que la langue française est sexiste ou
pas mais pour ce qui concerne le pronom
yale si je vous dit patrick j'aimerais
mieux qu'on dise yale en ce qui me
concerne et plus ils vous accepteriez
vous que ce serait contradictoire pour
moi je peux pas utiliser yale parce que
vous savez l'emploi d'un mot vous
identifie donc faudrait que je sois
transgenres en l'occurrence pour
utiliser yale d'autant plus que là il ya
quand même une contradiction parce que
yelle donc qui reprend i et elle
n'efface pas puisque les deux sont
présents sont qu'au présent donc c'est
le problème d'ailleurs que pose la
l'écriture impulsive est ce que on
soutient la binarité waskow contraire on
essaie d'effacer les genres voilà c'est
une grande question qui va être posée et
au delà d'ailleurs je dirais du genre se
pose la question de l'identité
parce que c'est ce qu'on peut définir
une identité quand on les fasse les
éléments les caractéristiques d'un
individu
moi je veux bien réagir pour dire que
justement la vraie question c'est pas
d'effacer c'est au contraire d'ajouter
c'est pas d'effacer c'est d'ajouter au
sens organique du terme une langue est
vivante donc une langue c'est un
organisme plus elle se complexifie plus
elle est à la fois précise des du point
de vue purement linguistique précise et
en même temps elle élargit le champ des
significations bien là c'est un
élargissement du champ des
significations ce qu'on parle
d'inclusion élargit le champ des
suicides signification et maintenant
c'est plus précis mais l'idée c'est pas
de faire de l'identité risme en sens
inverse et d'éliminer c'est pas du tout
ça ça c'est ce que font justement ceux
qui essayent de ceux qui prétendent que
l'enjeu ça serait effacée on parle de
caen de sel puncheurs et c'est tout à
fait à mauvais escient justement pour
pouvoir cibler cela alors que c'est en
fait un accroissement organique de la
langue c'est vrai que jusqu aux années
2000 on était soit un homme soit une
femme et même les trans beer et être en
somme outrance femmes c'est au début des
années 2000 qu avec l'acronyme lgbt
c'est à 2,7 a ajouté le cul le cul de
cuir j'ai l'impression que c'est à ce
moment là que tout à coup la non
binarité est devenu un genre à part
entière je me trompe je
ne voudrais pas dater exactement parce
que les formes de vie non binaire existe
depuis longtemps
ils ont pris de l'importance elles se
sont organisées avec le terme queer qui
donc visent à troubler cette vie marine
est là et donc à essayer de penser des
formes de vie qui trouvent cette vidéo
est donc en quoi c'est un problème somme
que tout à coup je dis je la tiens on va
rajouter une lettre à lgbt et puis on va
rajouter pourquoi pas apprenons c'est
pas un problème quel est le problème
alors c'est pas volé dix mois que je
considère que c'est le signe d'une
décadence c'est à dire en gros ce que
vient de dire lioger est intéressant
enfin je suis tout à fait en désaccord
avec lui mais il est moderne
la modernité c'est l'action il a bien
dit et ça c'est le vieux fantasme des
lumières venant ce que j'appelle le
syndrome de protagoras l'homme comme
étant la mesure de toute chose on agit
un descartes l'homme maître et
possesseur de la nature les lumières un
qui fait qu'on va agir sur le monde en
son entier et surtout en particulier et
c'est logique ça mais en même temps
quand quelque chose de décadent et bien
c'est les combats d'arrière-garde
ils deviennent plus violents plus carré
vaut le combat d'arrière garde en
l'occurrence c'est ce qu'ils ne veulent
pas entendre parler du pronom yale où
c'est ce qu'ils veulent voudrait le
faire entrer dans le vif ya sur ce que à
6 ans le combat d'arrière garde
tout simplement les lumières sont
devenus clignotantes ils se rendent pas
compte que c'est le retour de la
tradition vous à dire ceux lisais ce
matin une passe de simone veil
l'enracinement montrer comment après les
droits il fallait revenir aux devoirs
aux obligations et moi je pense que
c'est un peu ce qui est en jeu il ya
encore ces arrêts regarde là qui
considère qu'il faut changer le monde
agir sur le monde et c'est ça le touche
qu'une toute petite secte
des élites déphasé moi je vois quand je
vais dans mon village ce genre de
problème se pose pas alors là il ya un
décalage très fort qui existe chaque
fois qu'il y a que ces élites restent
sur des valeurs anciennes les lumières
se rendant pas compte ses lumières sont
devenus clignotantes et du coup mais ça
clignote fort bah ça clignote mais c'est
pas dangereux c'est pas un problème est
là
est ce que ce serait pas plutôt l'envers
justement cette crispation la de vouloir
absolument forcer une personne à
adopter une identité femme ou homme
quand elle ne contient lui parle pas par
exemple est-ce que et ce n'est pas
plutôt voilà un rapport à l'autre plus
ouverts à l'altérité plus doux plus
délicat de juste écouter
l'identité de l'autre écoute et son
positionnement et l'accepter en fait on
peut être il est elle à la fois moi j'ai
écrit dans un de mes livres j'en ai trop
écrit deux livres mais enfin dans un de
mes livres est écrit que dans le fond la
logique de l'identité était la logique
moderne bout d'un processus éducatif je
suis un homme ou une femme de gauche ou
de droite ceci ou cela et c est que au
contraire ce qu'était préalable à la
modernité pré moderne ce qui sera pour
moi la post modernité c'est les
identifications multiples et et pas où
est donc du coup on peut être ceci et
cela en même temps et moi je connais des
quantités attitude et quantité de
personnes qu'ils vont pas se reconnaître
dans ciel mais qui vont être peut-être
dans des moments différents il ou elle
pourquoi mais cela pour ça non mais cela
au travers d'un acronyme de cet endroit
que c'est pas utile enfin
c'est une attitude de vieux
réactionnaire
il
faut revenir quand même un peu sur le
fonctionnement du langage d'ailleurs
constamment ce que vous dites à
l'intérieur l'écriture exclusive il ya
débat effectivement entre les
transgenres qui veulent effacer la
binarité et ceux qui au contraire
veulent essayer systématiquement de
faire alterner les deux genres mais là
au départ qu'est ce qu'il ya au départ
c'est que ça a été introduit dans un
dictionnaire
d'abord savoir ce que c'est qu'un
dictionnaire un dictionnaire c'est pas
une autorité malgré ce qu'on dit dans
les jeux télévisés me un dictionnaire sa
enregistre un ca n'édicte pas de règle
les grammaires au contraire est dicté
des règles et on enregistre au sample
enregistré un boom tout simplement parce
qu'il est utilisé même même avec une
certaine récurrence d'une part par
exemple ils ont introduit vaccinodromes
distant ciel et c'est ce qui est tout à
fait justifiée parce que c'est devenu
très récurrent la pandémie oggy et que
ne serait ce que parce qu'on veut aller
chercher la définition faut bien la
trouver dans le nord mais le problème
dès qu'elle sait que c'est un mot
grammaticales et quand les dictionnaires
intègre un mot grammaticale c'est
toujours en se référant grammaire pour
que je sache il n'y a aucune grand mère
qui a introduit yale ah ça c'est un
premier point un bon et le deuxième
point c'est que bas il faut savoir
comment fonctionne le langage chacun est
tout à fait libre d'inventer les mots
qui veut ça c'est évident le problème
c'est que est ce que c'est un partage
social ou pas donc d'une manière
générale on enregistre ce qui se dit et
ce qui se dit de façon quand même assez
récurrente est assez général donc vous
pouvez toujours avoir des dictionnaires
spécialisés pour avoir un dictionnaire
d'écriture inclusive comme il ya des
dictionnaire d'argot comme il ya des
dictionnaires technique mais si vous
êtes dans un dictionnaire de langue
général et dans une grammaire il faut se
confirmer à ce qui est dans l' usage et
que je sache dit elle pour l'instant
n'est pas dans les usages
moi je veux dire une chose c'est que en
étant pas justement linguiste pas du
tout spécialiste dirais que ce qu'est
une langue quand même à la base c'est
une tentative de nommer le réel vraiment
de nommer le real alors après il ya des
rapports sociaux etc
ce à travers la langue puisque a manqué
qu'à montrer chomsky et même pierre
bourdieu mais déjà nommé le réel donc le
réel à s'est démultiplié a évolué dans
notre société donc quand pour nommer le
réel il faut bien aussi de nouveaux mots
ça c'est le premier point de vue
d'ailleurs m quelques définitions au fur
et à mesure le deux et c'est pour ça
c'est pour ça que moi je ne suis pas
d'accord avec tout je suis d'accord avec
ce qui est réellement inclusif qui est
organiquement inclusive tel que je le
définis c'est le deuxième point c'est
sur la question de la modernité qu'est
ce que c'est que la modernité la
modernité c'est la multiplicité des
modes d'existence dans un même espace
protégé par le droit ça veut dire la
modernité à la base moi je pense qu'il
ya une bifurcation au 19e siècle qui a
renversé la modernité contre elle même
qui a usurpé même son nom que j'appelle
l'industrialisme mais la modernité elle
même c'est pas contre les traditions
c'est au contraire le moment heidegger
l'avait bien vu que 10 c'est l'époque
des conceptions du monde c'est l'époque
des traditions de la multiplicité des
traditions c'est pour ça qu'ils ces
endroits qui vient droit supérieur qui
ne valait plus le ou l'autre et donc
c'est cette idée de neutralité qui déjà
prêt présent dans la modernité au nom de
quoi ou non dans d'un concept qui est le
concept de la subjectivité
transcendantale qu'on trouve par exemple
chez quand c'est à dire il ya une chose
qui ne peut pas être remise en cause
c'est ma subjectivité individuelle et la
subjectivité des groupes c'est ce qui
permet la multiplicité des religions
dans un même espace qui permet aux
individus de faire ce qu'ils veulent
d'être homosexuel transat aidera tout ce
qu'ils veulent donc ça veut dire que si
vous comprenez ce que j'ai dit en
premier à dire que la langue c'est ce
qu'il nomme le réel le réel produit par
la modernité plus ou moins
dialectiquement depuis le xviiie siècle
xviiie siècle eh bien ce sont des modes
de vie différents avec des subjectivités
qui se sont exprimés déployer développer
et qu'il faut bien nommer
donc c'est pour ça que je suis pour pour
si ça correspond à cette évolution et
que c'est organiquement veut dire
enrichissant pas si ça si ça restera un
langage par exemple moi je me suis battu
parce qu'à un moment parce que je suis
comment dire contre le fait qu'on ait
perdu l'usagé du de la parfait du
subjonctif parce que là c'est un
appauvrissement en revanche si à
l'introduction dans la dans la langue
chaque fois de deux nouveaux mots mêmes
de nouvelles formes et qu'elles sont
discutées aussi dans l'espace public
organiquement passer le tram les deux
font effectivement de la modernité moi
je pense que même dans ce sens là michel
et moderne puisque le temps des tribus
n'est possible que parce que c'est la
modernité qui l'a rendue possible dans
un monde purement traditionnel ça serait
juste impossible y en aurait qu'une
tribu la tradition traduirait
transmission unique enfin lieu devienne
employer le mot de neutralité dans votre
livre lina braunschweig que vous parlez
de neutre le neutre ça n'est pas la
neutralité en quoi notre époque a besoin
du neutre et j'ai l'impression que yelle
est une traduction neutre que vous
réclamez vous aussi disons que je fais
la distinction entre notre neutralité la
neutralité ce serait une forme passive
par rapport à ce qui existe là où le
neutre on va essayer de transformer en
suspendant les les binarité le pronom le
pronom yale permet justement de ne pas
choisir il ou elle permet de faire voilà
de faire exister
les personnes les être au delà de cette
distinction même si c'est une fiction
une fiction bien est-ce que ce neutre
chez les êtres sur lesquels puisque
c'est nous nous qui disons yale pour
quelqu'un parce qu'on ne veut pas se
demander si c'est un garçon une femme
c'est donc en fait on projette une
fiction c'était pas forcément une
fiction c'est un rapport à l'autre qui
n'est pas médiatisé principalement par
cette différence la balle à plein il ya
plein d'autres types de rapports à aux
autres personnes qui ne sont pas ou la
différence de genre n'est pas pertinente
c'est juste de pas prêt définir ce
qu'est l'eau nous c'est laisser l'autre
justement dans le dialogue organiquement
définir ce qui l'est c'est ça en fait
c'est pour ça que notre ise si j'ai bien
compris le livre de l'ina que vous avez
été un excellent et d'un excellent livre
c'est justement une à un exercice
organique c'est à dire de ces se lier
avec l'autre et progressivement faire
apparaître réellement ce qu'il est mais
concrètement puisque michel aime bien
les étymologique concrètement ça veut
dire croître ensemble c'est-à-dire
accroître progressivement se nourrir de
l'identité l'autre et ne pas imposer à
l'autre l'identité qu'on lui appose près
préalablement ses juges et ça devrait
généraliser le monde logiquement puisque
n'y aurait pas de raison de discriminer
les uns ou les autres en leur nom
utilisant un il ou elle et payet
pourquoi ne pas le faire pour tout le
monde systématiquement le rendre
obligatoire et non non mais pas pourquoi
pas bah je me laissais soit vous me dire
il pour moi
c'est pas pour rien c'est pas fait pour
interdire ces faits pour permettre et
belges théo permettez-moi noomiz le lit
elle emmène le concert s'est passé mais
si vous avez parce qu'on ne peut pas
alors en même temps on ne peut pas
complètement éliminé les a priori et
voilà exactement on peut pas
complètement amélie mais les a pris en
revanche qu'on peut faire c'est être au
plus proche parent jeu empathique de ce
que l'on suppose que l'autre désir est
donc en fonctionnant comme ça en
fonctionnant comme ça eh bien on arrive
à se mettre relativement sur la longueur
d'onde de l'autre ce qui est l'objet du
langage c'est à dire faire le moins de
violence possible il ya toujours une
violence minimal c'est bah c'est pas
c'est pas un absolu ne trizay c'est le
contraire d'un absolu c'est pour ça que
c'est le contraire de la neutralité qui
serait une sorte de posture en surplomb
c'est au contraire un exercice
continuelle cela une sorte d'ascétisme
de la langue normalement ce de tester
tisme de la langue cette neutralisation
devrait s'exercer à l'encontre vous fois
plus tôt à l'égard de tout le monde ne
croyez vous pas en fait la question
c'est essayer d'utiliser le pronom que
les personnes dans lequel les personnes
se reconnaissent et quand on ne sait pas
eh bien on peut vraiment c'est assez
facile de juste entendre les accords de
l'autre les accords des adjectifs que
l'autre utilisent de d'essayer de
comprendre comment est-ce que d'autrui
des tierces personnes se réfère à cette
personne enfin y'a plein de technique
pour justement
identifier les pronoms qui a percé une
base juridique toi tu le pouvons pas
laisser ce n'est non pas d'une solution
a dit que je dit que les égards que vous
manifester auprès des gens doivent être
auprès de tous a prédit donc assez vite
votre prono yelle sera obligatoire en
place c'est pour ça que je disais que
c'est très important d'envisager cette
notion de subjectivité transcendantale
parce que in fine et ce qui compte c'est
que l'autre s'il se présente à
l'évidence comme étant masculin des
signes de masculinité vraiment très
visible dans mes préjugés je vais
peut-être que c'est ce qu'il a envie que
je lui dise est il donc j'emploie il
mais si je si je n'arrive pas à le
déterminer a priori j'employais les si
je me rends compte dans le cours de la
conversation qu'ils préfèrent autre
chose et bien je glisse donc c'était le
jardin on voit bien qu'on est très très
loin de
la linguistique l'ordre des choses oui
non mais il faut pas dire simplement la
linguistique faut dire le phénomène de
fonctionnement de langage 1 dans lequel
d'ailleurs il ya ce qu'on appelle le
processus de neutralisation la
neutralisation ça existe à tous les
niveaux au niveau politique au niveau
syntaxique au niveau sémantique et c'est
ce qui a permis justement que quand on
voit l'évolution du latin aux français
par exemple vous savez que les cas là tu
as ça il ya un problème en français
parce que tous les cas latin les
terminaisons des cas là tu as alors que
dans les autres langues latines a été
maintenue l'alternance aux as en
français ça s'est affaibli en eux et
donc d'un seul coup vous savez tout un
tas de mots qui n'ont pas de marque
spécifique du genre élèves
universitaires journalistes et c'est
tout un tas de murcia d'être une démo
épicène etc comme on voudra et donc ça
c'est un problème en français c est un
véritable problème parce qu'il n'a pas
de marque alors la question c'est
comment on va faire pour marquer le
genre justement est bien là inventer des
pronoms d'abord parce que les pronoms
n'existait pas enfin on a utilisé un des
marques existent en latin enfin par
exemple vous avez créé discrédit de
crédit' à mama mama map en français
c'est mmm comme je veux savoir que ces
gemmes où tu aimes ou tu as ton qu'on a
créé des pronoms puis arrive le il est
le il vient de il est et il a mais les
deux se sont fusionnés aussi en eux ce
qui fait qu'à un moment donné jusqu'au
14e siècle par exemple même l'inde était
employée pour l'autre bon d'ailleurs
très bien ça pourrait être ça pourrait
convenir à la modernité justement bon
donc c'est pour dire que de toute façon
tout ça vient de l'usaj faut pas oublier
que la langue est oral avant d'être
écrite que dans toute l'histoire de la
constitution de la langue et la
grammaire il ya toujours une bagarre
entre eux
les graphistes qui essayait de coller le
plus possible à la phonétique disons et
un certain nombre de doctes de savants
qui voulait rétablir l'étymologie alors
présent vous écrivez femme avec un noeud
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
là bah oui parce que justement c'est
parce qu'il fallait rappeler féminin
donc vous avez un problème en français
qui est une langue casuistique dans son
histoire parce que il est très très
difficile de s'y retrouver alors qu'est
ce qui reste eh bien il reste la
possibilité de jouer l'alternance avec
les articles ça cette première chose et
puis ensuite
d'appliquer ce processus de
neutralisation alors ça évidemment ça
fait bondir un certain nombre de
personnes surtout autour du mot hommes
de neutralisation qui fait que si vous
dites par exemple au pluriel les
universitaires doivent
ils le feront pas d'exclusion de des
femmes pas d'exclusion des hommes non
plus il ya une catégorie globalisante
sada neutralisation globalisante voilà
qui un distinguo finalement les gens de
même dans au sens général nous dit le
journaliste doit
avoir un esprit critique
mais il doit le faire avec
avec mesure est ce que quand je dis le
journaliste et terrasses a exclu la
journaliste sa garde un caractère de
généralités qui englobe qui englobe
justement les gens et ça ça vient d'une
inde a fait c'est qu'on confond genre
grammatical et jean sexuée vous avez que
même pour les uns personnel en a voulu
parce que d'abord s'étonnant que robert
prennent vielle parce qu'il ya tout un
tas il y avait à lille y avait eu il y
avait un rôle aussi incommode et est-ce
que ça a un sens de dire yale évident
à l'évident au lieu de il est évident le
livre c'est un à personnel total pas
besoin le genre là n'est pas là présent
donc ça prouve bien que ça c'est un
genre grammatical qui le renvoie pas
comme vous dites forcément au réel il
fonctionne à l'intérieur de la langue et
qui n'a pas besoin ici de distinction de
gens d'ailleurs
si j'emploie yale en ce qui vous
concerne tous les deux je vais dire ya
les beaux il ya les belles où il ya les
boel ça c'est un problème compliqué qui
est la question de l'accord des
adjectifs oui alors aller compliquée à
la il ya différents types de pratiques
et à des personnes qui alterne le
masculin et le féminin dans les dents
les accords dans les phrases et à
l'écrit il ya la possibilité de mettre
un point médian donc dans la halle dans
le langage là où il ya les pourrait
avoir sa place c'est pour ça que ces
séries mentation que ces questions de
gens là sont une expérimentation qui
sont en cours et il n'y a pas de vala de
règles arrêtées sur comment faire c'est
ça émergent des personnes qui les
utilisent après je voudrais juste
revenir sur la question du du neutre du
genre neutre 20 de l'utilisation du
prénom il du pronom il est des mots
masculin pour désigner des cas généraux
qui pourrait inclure du féminin et du
masculin on est vraiment pour moi dans
une neutralité dans une source
neutralité dans une neutralité qui est
colorée pour le dire comme ça coloré du
masculin en fait et quand on est une
petite fille quand on est une femme
quand on est une jeune femme on a force
d'entendre un discours général même à
l'école sur les métiers par exemple à
force d'entendre hommes politiques en
force d'entendre le journaliste on voit
bien que on ne peut pas se projeter dans
ces existences là dans ces métiers là
dans ces professions là donc il ya
vraiment comme un impact du langage sur
les représentations et sur sa propre
place dans la société il ya un lien jour
j'ai pris aussi si vous prenez s'cusez
moi là par rapport à tous ces mots là ce
qu'on appelle les mots épi chaîne hbo
qui m'ont très bien la différence entre
jean grammaticales et jean sexuée vous
dit une personne est le personnage mais
une personne c'est du féminin genre
grammatical c'est du féminin
grammaticales le personnage c'est du
masculin grammaticales mais dans les
deux cas il y à pas depuis des
générations de sexe voilà donc une fois
de plus vous savez ce phénomène de
neutralisation qui fonctionne alors on
peut le ne pas l'accepter si on veut pas
l'accepter n'empêche que le
fonctionnement de la langue une fois de
plus consiste à essayer de rendre compte
quand même des usages pour que les gens
se comprennent quoi c'est ça bon alors
pour bamba dans trois quatre cinq
siècles effectivement ça ce sera
peut-être intégrer oui pourquoi pas plus
bien fait en tout cas la féminisation
des noms de métiers c'est une bonne
chose ça effectivement les rôles
chantant l'a donc du coup il y à une
féminisation d'un certain nombre de
métiers et et d'ailleurs on est allé les
chercher haut moyen-âge où les femmes
travaillaient et avait à peu près tout
des métiers qui ensuite ont été
réservées aux hommes ont fait une pause
on se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
cette semaine on va passer en revue
l'actualité économique une bonne partie
des économistes qui pensent que tout ce
qui a été fait a été bien fait que
structurellement l'économie va bien que
chômage a vraiment été vaincue que le
pib a augmenté moi je vois pas où sont
les fondamentaux qui sont bon ben non
justement problème c'est que la bourse
elles montrent simplement parce que les
banques centrales injectent de l'argent
le monde entier sous perfusion là on a
un vrai problème on ne sait pas comment
débrancher la perfusion quand vous
déversez comme ça et que vous endetter
pour faire 5 10 % de déficit budgétaire
évidemment vous avez un résidu qui
arrive en pipe et heureusement faut
arrêter de prendre les gens pour des
imbéciles et leur annoncer à chaque fois
que demain l'herbe est plus verte parce
que demain malheureusement l'est rebelle
et
[Musique]
depuis plus d'un an le président bak
ronde était convaincu que le retrait
annonce la chancelière allemande le
positionnerait comme le chef naturel
d'une europe à laquelle ils imposeraient
s'est vu la réalité allemande est venue
frapper ce plan de plein fouet ces olaf
scholz ministre des finances et chef du
parti social-démocrate située à gauche
qui a gagné les élections on est loin de
l'autonomie stratégique européenne
défendue par notre président pour une
europe qui protège l'allemagne a pris
conscience et assument de plus en plus
ouvertement quelle est la puissance
centrale en europe le programme commun
qu'il s'apprête à mettre en oeuvre ne va
pas dans le sens des intérêts français
[Musique]
ce débat avec lille à braunschweig qui
publie ne trees et aux liens qui
libèrent avec michel maffesoli l'auteur
de l'ère des bouleverse des soulèvements
pardon pas de gouvernement mieux que ça
raphaël liogier l'auteur de descente au
coeur du mal et patrick charaudeau qui a
écrit la langue n'est pas sexiste aux
éditions du bord de l'eau
michel maffesoli
qu'est ce que ça vous de cette
conversation convient d'avoir j'ai vu
chanter une tension autre chose
d'ailleurs je viens d'avoir au messager
regarde-moi effectué t'emmerde
[Rires]
non mais on pourrait discuter 0 on
pourrait discuter sur la modernité la
modernité on commence à employer ce mot
cbc baudelaire qui l'emploie 248 avant
d'époque médiévale it et de la modernité
c'est essentiellement d'ailleurs cela a
été dit moi c'est pas mon domaine donc
je peux pas trop en parler c'est là
c'est le subjectif c'est l'individu
c'est là le cogito ergo sum cartésien et
c'est donc quelque chose qui fait qu'on
est enfermé en soi même voilà et de fait
c'est cet individu le subjectivisme
heidegger puisque le lieu j'ai assité
heidegger et c'est une grande critique
de descartes et du subjectivisme et donc
je dirais que ce subjectivisme abouti de
mon point de vue à 7 sur le débat que
l'on a aujourd'hui c'est à dire qui est
un prochain débat abstrait à dire une
paranoïa
dans le sens étymologique du terme par
anne moyenne ses pensées par an aux
inters d'une paranoïa de quelques-uns et
mais qui ne sont plus du tout en prise
avec ce qu'est là je sais pas si c'est
là le rêve ou la réalité sociale à dire
que je vois pas très bien encore une
fois comment un tel des enfin ce débat
houleux ce qui est
promu au travers d'elle pas concrètement
tout ce qui est ce qu'on appelle le
gender fluide le fait qu' on peut
changer jo wil hahn hon binarité d'auto
pas vraiment pourquoi être refusée moi
j'ai signé je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
et je continue à le penser je ne suis
pas je suis considère que ça c'est
quelque chose d'une certaine caste qui
ne touchent pas grand monde bah c'est
tout et que pour moi le réel c'est
encore une fois comment un langage
permet d'être ensemble de parler
ensemble de se comprendre dans le sens
saint plus ferme et là il n'y a rien de
concret dans ses pairs il a fait une
fausse étymologie leurs oeuvres afin de
contrer une crèche est resté croître
avec voilà donc est ce à dire que le
ravec normes et ne pas tout à fait avec
les autres c'est ça
c'est agir avec avec les autres états et
donc dans ce sens là il est des moments
c'est pas la première fois qu'on a une
abstraction de cet ordre chaque fois
qu'il y à fin d'une époque dans des
périodes qui sont des périodes
crépusculaire à dire qu
on ne fait que balbutier sur ce qui est
en train de naître mais on reste
fondamentalement sur des valeurs qui
sont de mon point de vue dépassée et
ciel c'était uniquement une expression
de ce subjectivisme qui a dit que
j'appelais le syndrome son gros tagora
ce mois là c'était donc vous voyez ce
que je peux dire je me vois très bien
mais est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas dire
par la même occasion que non ce qui est
justement typique de notre époque c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on peut être
effectivement un être avec un sexe en
érection même et dessin ou un peu on a
des hommes d'aujourd'hui des hommes
selon l'état civil qui accouchent
moyennes paient même qu'on ait des
femmes selon les civils et une période
qui me fascine c'est là ce qu'on
appelait à l'époque quand on n'avait pas
peur des mots la décadence romaine
maintenant on dit que l'antiquité
tardive notamment dans la décadence
romaine eh bien on avait exactement des
positions pourrait ressembler à ce que
venait d'indiquer à dire qu'avec les
femmes avaient joué un rôle qui n'était
pas négligeable dans la république vous
dans l' empire et tout à l'avenant il y
avait des formes de moi j'écris un livre
sur l'orgie exemple il y avait la
promiscuité sexuelle et on le sait quand
on va à rome en voir encore comment les
bains étaient des jeux cet endroit donc
il n'y avait pas quelque chose de quêter
le moralisme ambiant qui le propre même
encore une fois de vouloir définir a
priori on disait c'est ça qu'il était la
femme de tous les bacs
exactement mais on voit bien des
quantités de phénomènes de cet ordre la
fin de la renaissance est exactement la
même chose vous voyez c'est à dire où on
avait
libertinage très fort et tout à
l'avenant donc ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que il ne faut pas vouloir
enfermer on peut être ceci et cela j'ai
dit tout à l'heure la grande logique qui
a marqué la modernité c'est le ou où est
notre logique logique traditionnelle
tels convois dans l'empiré romain et
c'est le et et moi je pense qu'un retour
de ce et et et que ce n'est pas
nécessaire de le modifier dans une
manière qui soit trop stricte par le yen
voilà c'est tout c'est un vrai problème
d'identité je vais vous donner un
exemple
c'est à dire le fait qu' on ne peut
prendre conscience de son identité quand
on est confronté à la différence quand
on est confronté à autre chose parce que
c'est la différence qui vous oblige à
vous poser la question de ce que vous
êtes une fois j'étais invité dans un
organisme international où il y avait
des anglais des allemands et des
français s'appelait triangle c'est dans
le cadre de deux d'un ensemble
francophone tu es le comité européen et
l'europe étaient représentés par des
anglais des allemands et des français
bon et on m'avait demandé d'intervenir
donc j'interviens et je leur demande
mais pourquoi ici pour représenter
l'europe n'y a que des anglais des
allemands des français et les anglais
les allemands me disent ah mais vous les
français vous résumer toute la latinité
alors j'ai dit bon bah allez dire ça aux
italiens allez dire ça aux espagnols
allez dire ça aux portugais pour qu'ils
nous on est des gens du nord des
cartésiens tout ça et c'est vous trouvez
ça tout à fait normal et du coup ça m'a
posé la question qu'est ce que je suis
eh ben pour les anglais les allemands je
suis un latin mais pour les espagnols je
suis plutôt un cartésien autrement dit
je suis une somme de différence c'est ça
l'identité c'est qu'on est toujours à
travers notre histoire multiples une
somme de différence
si on est une somme de différence ça
veut dire qu'il faut qu'il y ait des
différences comment m'identifier comme
en prendre conscience et de l'autre et
de moi si je ne travaille pas le train
la différence et c'est ça le problème
que pose cette tentative d'effacement
des différences ou parfois de
conjonction qui revient au même parce
que si je conjointe du coup je n'ai plus
à m'affronter à une différence donc ça
on le retour à travers le langage 1 et
moi j'avoue que c'est le problème que ça
notre pouce quand vous voulez effacer la
binarité ou du moins là ne trees est
ok on a compris ça peut donner un prénom
comme yell ça peut donner aussi
l'effacement des du sexe sur la carte
d'identité par exemple est-ce que ça
peut aller jusqu'à des toilettes qui
serait neutre ou en plus des deux
toilettes ou est-ce qu'on vote qui se
retrouvent tous dans les mêmes toilettes
sinon tous dans les temps les mêmes fall
est pourquoi pourquoi ajouter une
catégorie nécessairement fait c'est moi
ce qui m'a intéressé avec ce débat c'est
enfin et surtout la réaction épidermique
qu'il a créé dans l'espace public c'est
pour moi un symptôme de notre addiction
en fait à la à la binarité de notre
addiction un système de représentation
du monde et d'organisations du monde où
les êtres sont nécessairement des hommes
ou des femmes et il ne s'agit pas
seulement de dire les êtres ont
nécessairement des organes sexuels
masculins ou féminins mais surtout
d'avoir en plus de ça et bien des
manières de sa bise et des manières de
parler d occupation spécifique des modes
d'être et et nous voilà et donc pour moi
le yen vient troubler cet cette
représentation dual du monde enfin
lioger moi je crois que là on
si on a du mal à se comprendre c'est
parce que quelque part on parle pas le
même langage même si c'est le thème de
la deûle à 2 de l'émission c'est que
quand on parle le la modernité
plusieurs définitions moi je crois que
la modernité comme j'ai dit c'est la
multiplicité des modes d'existence
justement qui a pour objet de surmonter
les binarité est donc aujourd'hui ont
fini par surmonter les binarité qu'est
ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire que ce
n'est pas remettre en cause la
différence c'est adjoindre des
différences supplémentaires justement
c'est chaque fois de juin des
différences supplémentaires la véritable
abstraction la véritable attraction
c'est l'identité arrêter ces taxes est
de dire nous il ya une identité mais
l'identité qui est construite qui est
régulé qui a priori défini par l'état ou
par des groupes des groupes qui serait
dominant qui soit bourgeois ou autre je
veux pas employer des gros mots c'est ça
le pôle l'abstraction et c'est ça la
domination la modernité sa promesse
c'est de surmonter cela en acceptant
progressivement quand je dis
subjectivité transcendantale s'est pas
seulement l'individu au sens le plus
restrictif et égaux et du terme on peut
dire que ça c'est une pathologie de la
modernité moi j'appelle l'industrialisme
la marque et isation etc ce sera même
l'objet de mon prochain livre ce ce truc
là cette espèce de bifurcation mais
c'est arrivé progressivement
organiquement à faire exister cette
subjectivité aussi des groupes moi je
pense que michel peut-être sans le
savoir il est profondément moderne parce
que le temps des tribus c'est quoi le
temps des tribus c'est le temps de la
multiplicité des subjectivités qui ce
qui s'agglomèrent ensemble et qui ont
possibilité la possibilité même
d'exister parce qu'il existe cette
promesse moderne et c'est tolérance
moderne l'invention la question de la
décadence la décadence de l'empiré
romain il ya une multitude d'hypothèses
moi y'a une des hypothèses khimki kim
qui m'intéresse une des hypothèses c'est
que le l'empiré romain n'est pas mort
effectivement parce qu'ils auraient une
décadence avec des divisions orgiaque et
pudibonde
anachronique des projections actuelles
bien au contraire c'est la multiplicité
qui a permis à l'enppi roma ce qui lui a
donné sa puissance et à dire l'octroi du
droit de cité or de l'identité propre de
ce qui était né à rome on sait qu'il ya
des rois des départs sont des empereurs
qui étaient issus d'espagne ailleurs et
en fait lempire à un moment donné a eu
aussi vous avez reçu eric zemmour a eu
c'est eric zemmour c'est à dire des gens
qui à un moment donné se sont dit ce qui
compte c'est la romanité rien ne va plus
on s'est trop étendu il ya de tous les
côtés d aider des groupes qui ne sont
pas vraiment romain c'est pas des vrais
romain échos étions dit c'est la
décadence mais ils étaient eux-mêmes le
en fait le symptôme de la décadence
qu'ils dénonçaient et ce qui s'est passé
c'est que ce sont des révoltes ce sont
des révoltes de légions romaines et 106
constitué d'étrangers qui désirait être
romain parce que c'était le seul endroit
dans le monde connu comme ce qu'on
appelle le monde connu où on pouvait à
espérer une ascension sociale sans a
priori roues avec au moins - d'à priori
identitaire cette machine la s'étant
arrêtée parce qu'avec des identités
ristar homme est basse et les légions
romaines elle même qui se sont révoltés
contre l' empire donc ça veut dire que
la décadence il ya une question
d'identité dans la des gagnants c'est
quand justement une société trop
complexés comme la nôtre a peur la peur
ce que disait li na a peur de débat sur
l'évolution de la langue pour nommer des
réalités qui sont des réalités qui ont
qu'ils sont moi je le répète tout à fait
concrète
michel me fais un livre est ce que je
dis
n'est pas du tout le jeu ça me fait
réfléchir
non moi je suis à titre personnel
moderne tu as raison ce ciom un brin vue
rationaliste je suis producteur et
reproducteur pas ce que je décris c'est
pas sont pas mes convictions j'ai
toujours dit que tous mes livres c'était
le contraire de ce que j'étais à titre
personnel voilà donc moi mon analyse de
la postmodernité ça je me reconnais pas
dans ce qui est en train de naître
j'aime bien dire je suis en effet ce que
je viens de dire non moi ce que ce que
m'inspire ce que l'on est en train de
dire cieux le dit d'une manière un peu
logique que c'est que alors pour moi
c'est la décadence mais à deux pas
historiquement dans le sens simple du
terme est en train de tomber
l'individualisme moderne qui reposait
sur la dialectique en thèse antithèse
synthèse c'est à dire qu'on va dépasser
le contraire en synthèse et donc
l'individu alors je vais vous donner la
formule de des cardons autres on se dit
toujours la première on dit pas la fin
cogito ergo soumis marquer mais où je
pense donc je suis dans la forteresse de
mon esprit et cela aboutit bien
évidemment à cette espèce de truc figé
qui va être cette poussée à la
caricature csu victime qui est le yale
moi j'ai proposé dans le temps des
tribus le premier chapitre le glissement
de l'individu à la personne la personne
j'aurais pu le dire maintenant monde
portent des masques enfin des muselières
mais la personne c'est le masque de la
manière et c'est là la belle idée
rimbaldienne je est un autre c'est à
dire en termes de logique que c'est une
logique dite contradictory yale une
logique contradictoires yale nicolas de
cues à dire quand le contraire ne se
déplace pas en synthèse la coïncidence
est rosy troupe l'altérité qui ai vécu
en tant que tel je disais tout à l'heure
et pour moi c'est ce glissement de
l'individu à la personne pluriel le je
est un autre qui me paraît être la
marque de ce qui va se dessiner non pas
le jeu mais le nous en gros nous vont
soit et nous à la communauté le tribut
etc etc ce que refuse à bien des égards
ce que j'appelais l'imbécillité duel à
dire qu'ils veulent être figé restait
encore une fois sur un individu et ceci
et cela donc vous voyez ce que je sais
de dire moi c'est revenir à la tradition
trader est en effet transmettre ce qui a
été donné par le genre c'est-à-dire
lucrèce natura rerum la nature des
choses qui fait qu'il y a un homme une
femme il ya ceux ci à cela on peut être
successivement j'ai bien dit tout à
l'heure un homme et femme etc et chacun
d'entre nous peut l'être on a des
quantités d'expérience en ce sens mais
il n'en reste pas moins que voilà pour
moi il ya sur un glissement de cette
horde qui est en train de s'opérer voit
la logique habituelle et gallienne à une
logique contradictory émotions tenant
d'entrée pis les mots logique des
logiques contradictoires yale j'ai dit
nicolas de cues c'est à dire la
coïncidence des choses opposées ça tient
ensemble et pourtant ces différentes
questions que j'ai envie de vous poser
ses os x est ce que tout ça concerne
même les gens que vous pensez que ça
concerne à savoir je le disais tout à
l'heure les trans veulent être des
femmes ou des hommes ils veulent changer
de sexe mais pour devenir des femmes ou
des hommes aucun transmet en vie enfin
ma connaissance me trompe peut-être
aucun transmet envie d'être neutre il a
envie d'être un homme ou une femme selon
ses goûts après il va être homosexuels
hétérosexuels bisexuels tout est
possible je pense il faudrait déjà
s'abstenir de projeter sur des gens
qu'on ne connaît pas des désirs de
fixité des désirs de transformation
totale du monde enfin là on ne connaît
pas ces gens on en a pas sur le plateau
j'en connais plein
des personnes donc la question n'est pas
de neutraliser les identités encore une
fois ce n'est pas d'effacer les
différences en tout cas ma perspective
sur le neveu c'est plutôt de suspendre à
chaud et de réduire toutes les pratiques
sociales toutes les occurrences qui nous
placent systématiquement est connue me
demande en fait de l'extérieur d'être où
un homme ou une femme pour laisser
s'exprimer justement le et et houleux où
et féminins et masculins on pourrait par
exemple penser aux vestiaires manière de
s'habiller il s'agit pas de demander à
tout le monde s'habille pareil il s'agit
de laisser plus de possibilités pour les
femmes de porter des vêtements d'homme
ce qui leur est déjà plus tard le plus
possible mais aussi pour les âmes de
porter des vêtements de femme j'avais
les hommes s'habille en homme que depuis
le xiiie siècle avoir s'habille en femme
non mais c'est vrai tout le monde avait
des longues tuniques et ça a été une
vraie conquête d'avoir le droit de nous
habiller comme en avant il
s'agit pas parce que j'imagine que
s'agit d'interdire il s'agit pas
d'interdire je sais que ça finit
toujours par interdire
s'agit toujours côté amélie pourquoi
parce que justement mais quand on laisse
faire les choses il ya des groupes qui
finissent par interdire au nom de leurs
propres préjugés mais donc là la
neutralisation au contraire de la
neutralisation la neutralisation au
contraire de la neutralisation parce que
elle considère l'accrochage de rater
ça crache crash crash elles consistent
elles consistent à
dommage
mais que je la vole bien
là la nôtre il l'un autorisation
justement c'est très différent de la
neutralisation c'est l'homme j'ai
vraiment donné c'est que la
neutralisation c'est au nom de mes a
priori je ne trahis lise l'autre sa
subjectivité qui n'est pas seulement moi
je suis pas pro cartésien je pense que
la modernité va au delà des cartes c'est
des cartes c'était la proto modernité
qui s'est déployée ensuite y compris sur
les émotions là c'est pour ça que
j'emploie le mot de subjectivité c'est
l'ensemble de la subjectivité avec le
mental avec la raison et puis avec les
émotions avec tout ce que l'on veut
comment se définit comme on souhaite se
définit la neutralisation si j'ai
compris que 10 lille à la neutralisation
c'est chaque fois faire un effort pour
que une norme a priori ne s'impose pas
donc c'est pour permettre
la chose donc c'est pas à ben maintenant
on va plus pouvoir s'habiller comme ça
tout le monde on va devoir employer yale
porte mon nom enfin continuer à parler
employés il s'est donc un enrichissement
au contraire de ce que dit il est là je
connais beaucoup de transe femmes elles
veulent qu'on leur dise elle est en bien
et je connais aussi beaucoup de transcom
et veulent qu'on leur dise ce qu'il m'a
fantastique personne ne veut qu'on lui
dise riel
vous avez dit au début qu'il y avait
bien des personnes qui ces deux là
d'ailleurs que vient le prénom qu'ils
utilisent pour elle même donc il en
existe moi j'en connais des personnes
qui veulent qu'on utilise yale donc on
en revient à la première question si tu
veux qu'on appelle comme ça est ce qu'on
fait oui mais tu ne veux pas non que tu
sois tu ranges ou pas
mais de toute façon
bon la nutrition la
nutrinautes risation je ne comprends pas
bien mais la neutralisation en revanche
c'est quand même la neutralisation qui
permet par exemple le mariage pour tous
c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné on met
entre parenthèses si vous voulez des
différences puis ont créé une catégorie
globale bon c'est la neutralisation qui
permet par exemple l'égalité salariale
mais c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné
on ne s'occupe plus de savoir si ces
hommes ou femmes mais s'il ya
compétences d'un individu pour faire tel
travail et dans le domaine de la langue
ça fonctionne de la même façon c'est
qu'à un moment donné
le tient pas compte d'une différence et
on englobe dans une catégorie supérieure
alors cela dit qu' il y ait la
possibilité nouvelle de
d'identifier les gens de les nommer
pourquoi pas moi ça m'est égal cesser
les choses elles viendront comme ils
viendront un même si on veut absolument
dire le droit humain au lieu de droit
les droits de l'homme ça pose un
problème parce qu'on dit pas la même
chose en disant les droits humains les
droits de l'homme enfin bon si ça
s'impose tout sera fini par la gastro
lui disaient les droits de l'humanité ah
oui une
paralysie mais on nie pas la même chose
le palais droit subjectif on l'a c'est
vraiment la définition de base des
droits de l'homme mais on ne dit pas la
même chose dans tandis les droits
humains et les trois clubs enfin bon si
ça finit par
s'imposer pourquoi pas après tout il y a
toujours des phénomènes de mixité il ya
des phénomènes de créolisation il ya des
phénomènes de
rencontres de mélange etc bon bah
écoutez si ça se fait ça se fait
simplement ce que je constate par
rapport au langage c'est que ça ne peut
pas être on n'est pas en 1984 c'est pas
c'est pas là on ne peut pas obliger à
parler d'une certaine façon 1 comment
pour l'instant ce que l'on peut dire
pour tout ce qui concerne l'écriture
inclusive c'est que temps que l'édition
les médias il administration n'emploie
pas ces nouvelles formes ça ne va pas de
généraliser c'est tout maintenant dans
les rapports interpersonnels
on peut toujours essayer d'introduire
quelque chose puis on verra bien comment
l'autre réagi oui pourquoi pas mais il
faut quand même pas comprendre il faut
quand même pas confondre ce qui est de
l'ordre d'un phénomène
socialisation à travers le langage qui
permet que l'on
minimalement on essaye de se comprend je
sais bien qu'on se comprend jamais
exactement enfin qu'on essaye de se
comprendre et qu' on ne rajoute pas un
du côté de ce qui peut faire un peu
obstacle à la compréhension de l'autre
rompu dès dans un siècle ou deux je
serai pas là m'enfin si elle s'impose
pourquoi pas
mais dans votre raisonnement michel
maffesoli normalement
la modernité tant triomphante parce que
la modernité ne sait pas qu'en réalité
elle est condamnée que la post modernité
l'a déjà remplacé normalement tout le
monde devrait se précipiter sur yale or
ça n'est pas du tout le cas moi j'ai
fait une distinction entre le pouvoir et
la puissance contre ce qui est
l'institution et ce qui est instituant
alors la modernité elle est
l'institution c'est les élites au
pouvoir ce qui ont le pouvoir de dire et
de faire voilà journalistes de faire ou
celui d un utilitaire ministre le
ministre de l'éducation et ceux qui ont
le pouvoir de dire et de faire et à
certains moments c'est pas la première
fois moi j'aime bien mettre en
perspective à certains moments il ya un
décalage entre l'institut et l'institut
ans entre le pouvoir et la puissance -
m'intéresse la puissance le pouvoir ne
m'a jamais intéressé je considère y
tient
mais celle instituant et disons si la
sagesse populaire qui m'intéresse
fondamentalement et cette sagesse
populaire qui va se cristalliser un peu
comme goethe comme sein d'al parler de
la cristallisation il ya une au maire et
salle qui se créent mélo mer c'est la
sagesse populaire pour moi je suis un
type je suis un fils du peuple et je
suis attentif tout ce que j'ai écrit
bien du peuple un point c'est tout ce
que vous ne fait que cristalliser or il
se trouve que cette puissance ne va pas
se reconnaître dans ces jeux de langage
c'est tout non peut-être vance entend
s'en emparer si on le voit quand j'ai
dit ce que je veux dire s il ya une
distinction objectif vous avez raison de
dire qu'actuellement il ya ce côté ap ap
afin que j'ai dit abstrait verticale et
cetera qui veut imposer en les fantasmes
qui sont les leurs pourquoi pas mais
c'est la fin de la modernité c'est à
dire on voit pendant longtemps la
lumière d'une étoile morte dix des
astrophysiciens
de fait cette étoile les lumières le
20ème siècle s'est éteinte j'ai dit tout
à l'heure maintenant il ya que des trucs
un peu clignotant mais il n'en reste pas
moins que nous qui avons le pouvoir de
dire et de faire on reste sur cette
belle idée des lumières et pour moi ce
qui est en jeu dans le débat
d'aujourd'hui eh bien c'est ce décalage
qui existe encore une fois entre ce
pouvoir qui impose des mots et la
puissance qui ne se reconnaît pas dans
ces mots voilà moi j'ai pas peur ce que
disait la même chose on disait la même
chose quand j'étais petit des mots
anglais mais on est bon il ya une
scission des élites utiliser borg l'est
le peuple ne les utilisera jamais il y
avait grande différence entre ce qu'elle
est au cinéma voir le film avec des
sous-titrés ce qu'ils allaient voir des
films doublés aujourd'hui il n'y a plus
de films doublés aujourd'hui tout le
monde parle une sorte de sabir franck
onglet qu'on n'aurait jamais cru capable
d'envahir à ce point y compris votre
village
on est venu des colonisés sans même s'en
apercevoir
de là à ce que dans 50 10 ans tout le
monde dit elle il ya qu un pas je sais
que c est dire depuis tout à l'heure moi
je je considère qu'il y à bien des
égards retour de la tradition
actuellement voilà en fait ce qui
m'intéresse moi j'aime aussi les
puissances m'intéresse beaucoup les
mêmes fins les singularités les manières
dont mais ce que vous faites c'est que
j'ai l'impression vous avez une vision
du peuple qui est unique enfin qu'il ya
une vision du peuple comme une eau non
uniquement composé d'hommes et de femmes
or ces pratiques de yale elle émerge
n'ont pas de l'université non pas d'une
élite politique qu'elle émerge de valade
personnes deux communautés qui se
mobilisent en fait qui font partie du
peuple est en fait la question du peuple
qu avec ce gros ce gros mot en fait il
est composé de multiplicité de la
typicité identité de groupe et qu'il
faut aussi reconnaître et que c'est
cette idée d'imposer une vision unique
et homogène des identités me semble
aussi être une forme d'institution et
d'imposition l'avic juste très vite
juste le jeudi le mot de lucrèce tout à
le titre de lucrèce cette sagesse
populaire pose sur l'ordre des choses un
ordre des choses qui peut toujours être
transgressée et qui est régulièrement
transgresser mais sans que cela se pose
en loi mais ce n'est pas le pouvoir
instituant l'ordre des choses justement
servi tout à l'heure on n'a que que la
langue servait à nommer les choses en
fait il ya deux processus il ya le
processus qui sert à nommer le réel
effectivement pour communiquer que vous
l'avez dit pour qu'on s'entende plus ou
moins et puis la longue en fait elle
sert aussi à classer non seulement les
choses des choses et les personnes et
les groupes et donc cette fonction
classante c'est quand même une fonction
qui au maximum peut devenir
discriminatoire c'est une fonction
éminemment politique et donc c'est vrai
que lorsque on travaille à l'écriture
inclusive à la fois on est on comment
dire on capte ce qui monte de la
multiplicité des dépositions qui
existent dans la société au delà de la
simple binarité mais en même temps oui
on a aussi un désir d'avoir une action
qui est une action politique en
l'occurrence les une action politique
d'inclusion et d'ouverture dernier mot
il est alors le traîner ses c'est
vraiment au effectivement c'est qui va
se jouer sur le rapport de force vous
savez comment se sont construits les
dialectes par exemple
dans la conjonction de ces deux forces
une force centripète est une force
centrifuge la force de clocher comme
disait dialectal et dialectologue c'est
à dire que le groupe se replie sur
lui-même un don qui maintient un cc
propre emploi etc et puis la force d'un
terreau pour ce qui est le moment où on
s'ouvre au contact de l'autre sauf que
dans ce jeu là qu'est ce qu'ils gagnent
et ben c'est ça le problème ce sera le
rapport de force si à un moment donné
vous avez un groupe dominant par rapport
à l'autre et bas effectivement il va
imposer five a imposé de fait c'est
comme ça que s'est construit le français
entre la langue d'oc la langue d'oil et
c'est donc progressivement mais c'est
toujours un rapport de force c'est à
dire qu'il y aura toujours un moment
donné alors soit on tente dans la
créolisation c'est le grand thème de
d'edouard glissant la créolisation qui
fait que à ce moment là on a des
phénomènes de mixité ou bien alors on a
des rapports de domination d'un groupe à
l'autre avec des phénomènes
d'assimilation d'intégration etc donc on
verra bien pour l'instant c'est pas le
cas mais si un jour ça devient
d'occident et ben voilà tout le monde
parlera en lits à lui merci tous les
quatre d'avoir participé à ce débat
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
et